moi je viens de porter plainte je dois
dire que la police a été parfaite ils
m'ont accompagné ce qui s'est passé une
énième salle de menaces précises
avec des localisations qui font peur
c'est-à-dire des gens qui savaient vous
habitez tout ça
et vous avez quoi des intimidations oui
et l'adresse diffusée voilà quoi sur les
réseaux ou pas sur les réseaux sur les
réseaux là c'était sur les réseaux ça
m'était déjà arrivé par courrier j'avais
déjà déposé plainte là c'était sur les
réseaux donc je suis allé déposer
plainte et le responsable de la police
il m'a appelé j'ai déposé plainte le
jeudi donc lui il a trouvé la plainte le
lundi matin il m'a appelé dans la foulée
on est resté une heure au téléphone et
pourquoi pour
si vous le permettez
les menaces c'était clairement de venir
chez moi sans prendre à moi
et pas qu'à moi d'accord
j'ai été très inquiet vous êtes toujours
ouais
oui je suis inquiet une fois ici j'ai
pensé de suivi et Mokhtar et les équipes
m'ont appelé en demandant à la voiture
qui me ramenait de faire plusieurs tours
le policier m'a expliqué que quand je
rentrais chez moi fallait pas que je
rentre directement que je fasse des
tours que je sois prudent il m'a dit
aussi de faire attention
quand je prends les transports en commun
moi je veux pas changer de vie mais il
m'a dit il faut faire attention voilà
ouais j'en parle avec émotion parce que
il m'a moi j'ai tendance à un peu être
bravache et lui là il m'a dit Gilles je
vous appelle je vous le dis clairement
faites attention alors ça c'est suite à
vos prises de position
c'est des salves sur les réseaux sociaux
qui sont liés à mes prises de position
c'est souvent les mêmes sujets c'est
quand je dis globalement je vais résumer
mais que les squatteurs on peut pas les
jeter dehors comme ça c'est quand je dis
que
les pédophiles sont ce qu'ils font et
monstrueux mais ce sont pas des monstres
voilà et à chaque fois c'est un
déchaînement sur les derrière mais c'est
quoi donc c'est un déchaînement et on je
vais vous dire aussi quelque chose j'ai
je sais pas faire de comment on dit de
screen de d'écran là je suis nul
là-dedans et dimanche
j'ai reçu un message je veux pas vous
donner la tonalité mais c'est le plus
ignoble message que j'ai jamais reçu et
depuis donc ça c'était dimanche j'ai
voulu le le montrer ici à aux équipes
mais il a été retiré par la personne
c'était tellement
ignoble que j'ai osé en parler à
personne et je me suis dit là c'est on
dépasse tout quoi j'ai failli venir vous
voir vous auriez dû j'aurais dû ben vous
auriez oui mais j'aurais dû bien sûr que
j'aurais dû puis je sais que dans ces
cas-là vous êtes toujours là mais j'ai
pas le message était je vous dis pas ce
qui était le message il était tellement
ignoble que j'ai dit c'était quoi sur
quel réseau sur les sur insta c'était
non c'était Twitter Twitter et j'ai dit
si on en arrive là quand on prend une
position même si mes positions suscite
des désaccords
d'accord avec lui maintenant c'est un
garçon moi que j'aime vraiment
profondément vous le savez c'est
vraiment c'est c'est un des plus fidèles
et c'est à quelqu'un qui j'ai une
confiance absolue quelqu'un voilà qui
est souvent pas d'accord avec moi sur
beaucoup de sujets mais c'est ça qui
fait qu'on est aussi très proche et on
peut s'engueuler comme vous je peux
avoir parfois les nerfs contre lui sur
des positions qui prend dans l'émission
mais c'est quelqu'un que c'est
extraordinaire c'est quelqu'un qui est
toujours là pour aider les autres et
joue au contraire toutes ces positions
sont à l'image de ce qu'il est dans la
vie c'est à dire que Gilles il aimerait
il aimerait aider tout le monde il
aimerait voilà il est tout le monde
vraiment que tout le monde puisse être
pardonner que tout le monde puisse avoir
une deuxième une troisième une quatrième
ou une cinquième chance et c'est ça qui
lui est reproché et Gilles ça reflète
bien son caractère c'est que il est
Gilles voilà profondément genre
profondément gentil et voilà et
aujourd'hui j'ai c'est vrai que je sais
que tu es je sais parce que même les
équipes me l'ont dit
il est extrêmement inquiet donc j'ai
voilà j'ai dit aux équipes de de de ces
mots au plus près de toi et je sais que
toi voilà c'est vrai que la célébrité et
ton je veux dire ton excellence dans
l'émission fait aujourd'hui que ça te
fait ça te fait des des soucis et et des
gros problèmes Mathieu vous l'avez dit à
l'époque aussi je crois que maintenant
moi voilà
mais c'est vraiment je le cherchais mais
je pense que j'ai bloqué la semaine
dernière j'ai reçu parce que quand je
suis sur les réseaux on s'en tape je
vais la vérité je regarde même pas les
réseaux je vous dire un tiers d'insultes
un tiers de 1/3 de gentillesse et en
général un tiers de messages aberrant je
regarde même pas je m'en tape mais quand
c'est sur votre texto je crois que
c'était à 10 jours j'ai reçu ouais par
texto dès que tu descends de chez toi on
sera là
en vrai
je l'ai bloqué j'ai passé pourquoi j'ai
mis nom parce que moi tu m'en as pas
parlé et tu vas faire quoi
le numéro pourquoi j'ai mis non c'est
même si c'est une carte je t'explique
non
je le dis aussi mais c'est des
téléphones
le téléphone je retrouve le mec d'où il
l'a fait et je vais le retrouver très
vite mais en l'occurrence ce qui est
toujours agaçant avec la police et Dieu
sait si je l'aime c'est que quand tu vas
aller voir et que tu leur dis tout ça et
te disent tant qu'il est pas passé à
l'acte c'est adorable mais bon si tu
vois en fait tant que tu es vivant tu
risques rien bon mais le truc c'est que
moi il y a deux choses qui me rassure un
peu la première c'est que on a un petit
peu plus accès et je le reconnais c'est
une vraie chance quand on est une
célébrité un petit peu connu on a un
petit peu plus accès à la police quand
je m'étais fait agresser par un
chauffeur de taxi j'ai appelé la BAC
quatre heures après il était il était il
était dans les dans le commissariat et
il y avait un face à face c'est une
chance gigantesque sont pas la plupart
des gens qui vont porter plainte c'est
une chance gigantesque en revanche tu
vois je te dire quelque chose tu
m'aurais dit à 10 ans je prends la garde
du corps mais j'aurais été grotesque
garde du corps c'est Madonna je me
serais balayé avec un garde du corps
mais pourquoi pas derrière cette année
j'y pense je vais le payer sur ma
société parce que du coup tu as le droit
de prendre son société et non pas parce
que je suis une stable parce que j'ai
peur alors quand j'ai mis non c'est
juste parce que je suis sauvé entre
guillemets un petit peu par le fait
qu'on est voilà et parce que j'ai les
moyens peut-être de me défendre et ça va
me rassurer mais tout le monde les a pas
merci d'ailleurs un petit peu grâce à
toi mais si on avait dit un jour
aussi
pour faire le métier que tu aimes et le
métier dont tu rêvais petit un jour tu
auras un garde du corps parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on pense c'est
très drôle 3 jours parce que tu te
prends pour une rock star mais c'est
insupportable tu as quelqu'un qui est là
tout le temps et tout c'est pas drôle du
tout un jour tu aurais ça franchement
j'ai pas cru Valérie
c'est à cause de moi c'est pas du tout à
cause de vous Cyril
qui est exac
épidermique et où toute prise de
position va faire que évidemment un
Français sur deux va être d'accord avec
vous
et d'ailleurs je voudrais vous en
remercier et Lionel stanle également
parce que en l'occurrence vous m'avez
mis à garde du corps parce que il y a
quelqu'un qui est venu ici pour s'en
prendre à moi physiquement qui a été
interpellé par la BAC qui est venu à
deux reprises à la deuxième reprise il a
été arrêté et qui voulait beaucoup
énormément bouleversé
parce que je ne m'y attendais absolument
pas parce que je pensais justement qu'on
est dans une démocratie parce que
société où on peut débattre y compris ne
pas être d'accord y compris ne pas être
d'accord de façon extrêmement forte je
vais vous dire je pense avec ça ça
rejoint aussi même les et je le redis
encore vous allez me dire où il est fou
il accent en tête mais ça rejoint aussi
les deux noms de son qui qui nous
reprochent parfois d'avoir une jeune
fille voilée dans l'émission ou bien de
recevoir un représentant du
rassemblement national ça aussi c'est
aussi de l'intolérance et et c'est voilà
c'est c'est aussi la liberté
d'expression il se prône tous la liberté
d'expression tous les bien-pensants tous
les donneurs de leçons mais aujourd'hui
la liberté d'expression la plus claire
la plus la plus poussée elle est dans
Touche pas à mon poste je suis désolé il
y a pas une émission ou où on invite
autant de gens différents et autant de
témoignages différents et donc c'est
vrai que ça aussi je vous dis les gens
et je le dis pour moi les responsables
aussi ce sont ceux qui mettent de
l'huile sur le feu comme les les
biensants qui font des tweets les Sofia
Aram de France Inter qui fait des tweets
très très violents sur vous sur les ce
qui se passe dans l'émission alors que
voilà personne la connaît elle essaie
d'être drôle à chaque fois c'est à coté
et c'est une ni drôle mais c'est
dangereux donc ça c'est loin c'est
dangereux et quand on s'en prend à eux
ça c'est sur nous que ça retombe c'est
un moment donc tu sais plus quoi faire
mais à un moment comme je dis un moment
ça on va on va être obligé d'être
plus méchant que et là ça va être plus
compliqué Jean-Mi oui alors évidemment
en préambule il y a beaucoup plus
d'avantages que d'inconvénients
encore quand même j'avais des menaces
mais dernièrement j'étais victime d'un
tentation de son pas d'une tentative de
chantage d'extors sont de fond quoi
parce que je m'étais livré j'étais
célibataire à ce moment-là et évidemment
quand on est un peu connu on reçoit
beaucoup plus de messages comme par
hasard de jeunes filles jolies qui vous
écrivent que quand vous étiez
voilà et du coup je m'étais célibataire
j'avais commencé à échanger avec cette
jeune fille là on s'est échangé des
photos etc et moi j'étais en pleine
confiance parce que vraiment c'était ça
faisait tellement de temps que c'était
monté progressivement qu'on s'est chanté
de messages on se racontait nos vies de
façon plus intime etc jusqu'au jour où
quelqu'un de public m'a appelé un
journaliste de public que je connaissais
un peu m'a appelé me disant est-ce que
c'est normal qu'on reçoit des photos de
toi plutôt intime à la rédaction etc etc
en fait je me du coup j'ai écrit la
personne qui tout de suite là sachant
qu'elle était dévoilée qu'elle était
révélée m'a dit qu'elle réclamait 25000
euros pour cesser de d'essayer de vendre
ses photos là au magazine au magazine en
caisse au magazine voilà les magazine
m'ont dit de façon on ne fera jamais
paraître ce genre de photos mais sache
que ça circule qu'il y a des gens qui
conseille de les vendre j'ai contacté la
police qui a essayé de donner
rendez-vous d'essayer le piège de cette
personne-là qui prenait vraiment des
précautions et des téléphones avec des
cartes des cartes prépayées etc ils ont
donné un rendez-vous la personne avait
dû se méfier ils ont pas réussi à la
choper et après ça c'est un peu calmé
mais vraiment j'ai vraiment je me suis
dit j'ai quand même eu un peu peur parce
que ça devenait vraiment très très
intime quoi